let's talk about what the Deep state
will do if you come after them I hate
him passionately Tucker Carlson unloads
on Trump in text messages what's strange
the day after Tucker Carlson releases
definitive evidence that the j6
committing Democrats and many
Republicans and the media are lying text
messages get released smearing Tucker
and framing it as though he hates Donald
Trump the funny thing is there are
photos of Tucker Carlson laughing and
hanging out with Trump
this is two things
a distraction and an attack stop people
from talking so when you search Tucker
Carlson right now you'll see so earlier
today I'm doing research on all these
stories talk across and drops these
videos when I searched I could cross it
on Google what do I get I get the text
messages story
something salacious to keep the left
focused on it's not so much for the
right the right's going to be like yeah
a Tucker can say that that's fine people
on the right are more understanding and
willing to accept there not everybody
likes Trump but they're going to try and
win that argument Tucker has done too
much good and there's gonna be some
people like ah whatever who cares but
the left will now watch this instead of
the j6 footage debunking the lies from
Democrats yeah well I think Tucker
effectively became a j6er this week in a
way I mean it's like the media is now I
think going to start treating him the
way they've treated every person who's
been arrested on January 6 and
everything that they put us through I
mean again when I got through my house
arrest and I started doing media and
telling my story for a long time I mean
for like almost a year I was like the
only j6er out talking and sharing my
story and they have beaten the hell out
of me I mean honestly in many ways the
worst part of my j6 experience happened
after my sentencing because when I
started talking about it and I started
making clear that I was not going to
allow this to destroy my career or my
life that I was going to come back from
this I was going to fight back that's
when they got nasty or nastier and I
actually I keep saying I think that the
media there we all know that the media
is what the media is but they they've
almost become like they see themselves
as a prosecutorial arm of the democratic
party
um I mean there were reporters from CNN
contacting my prosecutor and giving
evidence to my prosecutor and saying
like you should you should think twice
about giving him a plea deal have you
seen this and have you seen this when
have you ever heard of reporters doing
that yep on the Vanguard yeah yeah
they're the Vanguard trying to Usher
through Usher the proletariat through
the revolution yeah I think there are so
many progressives who go into journalism
to be uh activists absolutely they're
not there to just present stories and
give you a fact and let you draw a
conclusion on your own they want to
control the narrative and unfortunately
it's something that they've been able to
do on all fronts right journalism is not
about truth it's about their truth yeah
so when you were incarcerated after
January 6th can you talk about what that
was like because you did the um display
at CPAC was it the year before where you
see back Dallas yeah yeah in August and
I don't know if everyone knows what it
was but there was a jail cell right yeah
so I did essentially a performance art
piece at CPAC where we erected a
life-size uh prison cell eight by eight
I mean the only difference is that uh it
had bars in our an actual prison cell
like the j6ers are being held in is
concrete bricks and a metal door where
these people many of them are in
solitary confinement have been for years
uh which is insane because that's I mean
I was look I was in there for two and a
half days okay like it was and in that
two and a half days I was also not let
out but by the time I got out after two
and a half days like I I was I I mean
like my nervous system was like on fire
I was like get me the hell out of here
if I had been there for two years like
these people are never many people are
still in yes they're never going to be
okay like these people they're they're
going to be gone like there's no way way
a person can survive and they say
they're doing this for their protection
or like what's the justification on
solitary confinement I I think that they
put them in a special Ward which they
have said is for their protection
protection but they um I mean there's
all sorts of excuses that they can use
they can say oh covid or maybe somebody
tested positive
um I I don't know the justification
necessarily for it going on as long as
it has
um I know that they're being treated
horribly I mean there's there have been
beatings one person I we keep hearing
lost in I I don't know if that's literal
or if he was just blinded or what
happened but apparently he had the hell
beaten out of him
um you know food that's being you know
served to them inedibly and you know
destroyed so they get they don't have
access to their lawyers calls with their
families
um it's really pretty horrifying but so
I was kind of trying to draw attention
to that cause and unfortunately because
the right-wing media overwhelmingly is
so cowardly and afraid to even talk
about January 6 or touch this which is
another reason why it was so difficult
for me to get as my story out as much as
I wanted to
um very few in the right wing media
actually covered my performance art
piece at CPAC which by the way was
actually amazing I mean it was actually
me I don't know cool and different yeah
no offensive CPAC but like you need new
fresh things yeah and when I say amazing
I don't mean like I'm amazing what I
mean is that we had hundreds of people
lined up to see it because what I did
was we erected a life-size cell I put on
an orange jumpsuit and a Maga hat got
inside it and I kind of like sat in
various poses not saying anything and
not interacting with the audience I
allowed them to come they could talk to
me they could pray they could do
whatever they wanted to but I didn't
interact all I had was a chalkboard on
the black wall and I would keep getting
up and changing the messages to say
things like where is everybody why am I
alone what you know know things like
that and then we had audio Yeah I was
going to ask about the audio component
yeah so we had 20 or 30 wireless
headsets and people could come and they
could put the headsets on and while they
were kind of looking at the visual which
was me in the cell we had three
different channels they could switch
between which were the voices of real
j6ers telling their stories about being
raided by the FBI by being abducted by
being taken and put in a cell and the
charges they faced and what it was like
going through the doj it was very
powerful and people were like weeping
and watching this it was amazing and
then of course only the left-wing media
was there so all you heard about was
this unhinged CPAC performance you know
that was like a carnival and yeah at one
point Marjorie Taylor green did come
inside and she held my hands and she
prayed and I mean it was lovely but a
lot of people were unwilling to interact
with what you had set up
oh no no from the audience no I mean
like a lot of uh conservative public
figures that might be at Sea bag like
Margaret Taylor green went up to it but
she did um yeah there weren't that many
uh like uh you know big personalities
that came in were a part of it but I'm
even just talking about the media I mean
it wasn't reported on by Fox News or
Newsmax or I mean pretty much anybody on
the right so the coverage was you know
we just got dragged so hard with them
except on Twitter that's where I heard
about it because they're that year and
like Twitter was in love with it or at
least conservative Twitter was like this
I must have missed those tweets see I
got see people with I wasn't on Twitter
at the time and people would text them
to me and they'd be like this is just
unusual it's different and I think
especially for you know conferences
people want to expect performance art
but I think so many people have
questions about what happened to the
January 6 people right like even if you
don't agree with the violence and you
don't support it there are so many
unanswered questions that I think a lot
of people want answers to and that's why
I ask like why do you think it that
people can't grasp that domestic
terrorists are left-wing in America
because for so long we've been fed you
know conservatives have guns
conservatives are violent conservatives
are this that and the other like look at
Ruby Ridge look at all these things like
there is a an idea that because they
want to be left alone or you know
they're more interested in safeguarding
their own rights they don't want to
comply with this larger narrative that
conservatives are the ones who we have
to be nervous about
sorry that's what I think is
um is great about what Tucker's doing is
that he's it doesn't erase the imagery
of people who you know broke windows or
fought with police officers of course
not and nobody's saying that like
nobody's trying to rewrite the narrative
and act like the violence didn't happen
what we're trying to do is provide a
little more nuance and context here and
also to point out just because a person
got arrested or charged doesn't mean
that they were a part of the let's
overthrow the government gang why didn't
Trump just pardon everybody
can't answer that question
he should have pardoned a lot of people
I don't know about everybody but a lot
of them yeah
um I suppose how do you get everybody's
name how do you
I mean I know a bunch of The Proud boys
were just on trial for the first time
this year did he can you pardon someone
before they've been officially yeah I
think you can yeah yeah and so he just
didn't do it do you think he'll talk
about it going like well he said now
they should all be let go he's the he
came out on Truth social saying
following the release of the footage all
of these people should be released yeah
look uh you know I get very angry and
very defensive about people making
public statements about January 6th
without
effectively kind of like doing the due
diligence or the work behind the scenes
look I can tell you I have never been
contacted in two years by any of these
people who and it's really frustrating
um you know I have even heard Trump kind
of give credit to certain members of
Congress and talk about what amazing
work they're doing on the subject of j6
and I'm like no they're not like no
they're not ask any person who's gone
through January 6 who's helping them the
answer is nobody yeah nobody's helping
nobody's helping me people effective at
Junior six are helping themselves so
like when I went to the proud boys trial
a couple in in January I sat with people
whose family members are part of this
and they're saying like well we made our
own groups and we found each other
therapists to talk to when we found each
other like resources because basically
no one wants to talk to us about it we
can't get any media outreach and also
like we are really dealing with what the
effects of having someone incarcerated
because of this like we have legal bills
like if we want to be in trial and
they're in trial in DC and we're from
Nevada right like we have to be here we
have to put our lives on hold somewhere
else like it's an incredible burden not
only obviously on the people who are
incarcerated but on the other people who
are affected by it it's unbelievable and
I mean the amount of money that it costs
to go through something like this I I
mean it's and these are a lot of these
are very poor people you know and it's
it's not even a matter of you know well
this person should be paying their legal
bills or whatever but it's like man one
post on Truth social saying you know
everyone donate to this fund I mean it
could raise 10 million dollars in 24
hours and you know now everyone's
actually got representation thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time